[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines but the Daily
Mirror Economist Susie Boniface and the
writer Benedict Spence they'll be with
us from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
well the mirror it doesn't think much of
tonight's World Cup result for England
their headline yawn in the USA
the star has exactly the same headline
and it's almost like the three red tops
had a meeting because the sun has that
Splash too
but the male tries to be optimistic
looking ahead to England and wells's
match against each other on Monday and
calling it The Battle of Britain
the financial times hears that the
Qatari government is reviewing its
investments in London after ads
promoting Qatar were banned on the
city's public transport Network
according to the eye there are fears in
conservative circles that recent
announcements from a clutch of their MPS
that they don't intend to stand at the
next election could lead to more of
their colleagues making the same
decision
the express has seen research showing
that parents are having to dip into
their Pension funds to help their adult
children with the cost of living crisis
the times reports the chief Constable of
Greater Manchester police has told his
officers not to tweet opinions about
social issues
the guardian understands that some
disabled residents who use housing
provided by the charity Leonard Cheshire
are being evicted because of disputes
between the organization and local
authorities
and the telegraph speaks to the Princess
of Wales about early childhood education
of course close to her heart
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Susie Boniface and Benedict Spence
welcome to both of you thanks for
joining us let's start with the times
and this is this shocking review Into
the London fire brigade I mean truly
truly shocking some of the detail and in
this article start us off on this one
Susie
yeah well this is a review into what
exactly what's been happening in London
fire brigade and it's pretty horrifying
women are uh taunted they are having not
just remarks made about them but they're
being sent videos of their colleagues
flashing genitalia there's multiple
cases of bullying targeting rifting
minorities uh firefighters of color
having nooses left in their lockers and
anti-terrorism stickers put on their
lockers it's all pretty Grim reading
what's even more horrifying is that
Danny cotton who was the first female to
lead London fire brigade she was the
commissioner she herself got death
threats um after she was launching a
sexism camp and anti-sexism campaign so
no one seems to be immune it goes all
the way to the top and partly you can
say well yeah it's uh it's a
traditionally male environment and you
know lots of looks together in a very
testosterone-fueled situation are going
to be like this if you're going to be
really negative and pessimistic humans
that's what you might say and on the
other hand you say well it's the 21st
century chaps and women have been in
your workplace for quite a long time and
so have people of color and people of
other ethnicities and religions and this
isn't really the way to carry on is it
and so what's really refreshing about it
is that the fire brigade of seeing this
review and that mayor of London had gone
yeah okay fine that's that's all
terrible and bad and we're gonna fix it
which is I think might be one of the
first times in recent history I can
remember those in Authority being told
something has gone horribly wrong and
immediately just accepting that and
saying it needs to change quite often
they tend to try to prevaricate and
argue with someone else's fault they're
not doing that this time no the the
grades commissioner Andy Rowe um has
opened an independent investigation and
in a statement has said there is no
place for discrimination harassment and
bullying in the Brigade and from today
it will be completely clear to all staff
what behavior isn't acceptable and what
the consequences will be I'm deeply
sorry for the harm that has been caused
Benedict
yeah so I think they've probably seen
what's happened for example in the
metropolitan police and how the
Metropolitan Police has very sort of
been been very unimpressive in many ways
how it responded to allegations of sort
of rampant sexism and bullying and
everything else that's gone on it's done
many of the similar things that have
been uh leveled at the uh at the fire
brigade here but also yeah as Susie says
in sort of a more traditionally
masculine roles we see this a lot in the
armed forces as well
um a lot of bullying goes on and very
often the Temptation is to sort of close
ranks
um I think in many ways though uh the
first thing we do have to say is we're
not sure how widespread it is it might
be a sort of a a small core very
determined very nasty people it could be
ramping throughout we're not quite sure
but I think that the key thing that has
been said here is you know much more so
than perhaps you know for example the
Armed Forces
um in in the short term if you're
working as part of a fire again if
you're working as part of a team it is
essential actually that there is
camaraderie that there is teamwork that
there is trust and actually you you have
to stamp out that sort of bullying that
sort of internal fractures very quickly
because it's not actually like you can
just be sort of deployed somewhere else
or shifted off to a to another unit or
to a desk job or something like that if
you get the call you have to go out
straight away this isn't actually a
profession that you you can sort of hide
behind
um uh hide behind protocol or you know
or sort of offer sort of you know minor
platitudes this is something that does
need to be nipped in the bud um it's a
very dangerous job it's a very demanding
job and I think probably it's just the
sort of thing where ultimately even if
there was a desire to Shield those who
are responsible I just don't think
there's the capacity for them to be able
to get away with it no Susie to the eye
and this story about conservatives being
worried that many MPS are choosing not
to stand again the article mentions um I
think three that dehena Davidson becomes
a third we
um think that the figure's probably
closer to to eight
is it a trend
well now what's happened is the Tory
party has given its members a deadline
of early December to say are you
standing or not at the next election
because they want to have some time
um ahead of any likely election to
actually vet new candidates and make
sure they're not complete lunatics
because doing things at the last minute
doesn't usually work out
um so ahead of that deadline there are a
number of MPS who've decided Well I yeah
no I think I'm going to be off actually
I've got other stuff I could be doing
um and if you actually talk to lots of
people sort of behind the scenes and off
camera and things like that most
conservative MPS that I speak to
um are fully aware that they are heading
for a period in opposition they expect
that to happen next time
um I think to be honest people we lost
the next election in Barnard Castle but
all the things that have happened since
then I just made it far far more likely
and the whole reason and the the purpose
of getting Rishi sunak in place in a
sense and so the party could have
someone there under whom they would lose
less than sadly than they would have
done under either Liz truss or Boris
Johnson
so it's just a case that you know there
are people who are being realistic uh I
unfortunately it probably means the ones
who are going now are the ones who are
more practical and the ones who probably
have transferable skills and have other
other things they could be doing whereas
the absolute no hope is who who couldn't
get a job in Audi are going to be
staying in Parliament
um which is not good for anybody but
we'll just have to see how it goes don't
we I'm sure that label will be having a
similar list and deadline as well for
people do you want to sign up now or not
and we won't see the same kind of Exodus
Because by the same token the labor
party expects to be in government next
time just to say that all Supermarket
work is Honorable let's move on to the
espresso and this story relating to the
cost of living crisis Benedict and many
um parents dipping into their pensions
to help their their adult children out
sure um this I mean that's really
something that sums it up quite well and
I think that's a that's a sign really
about how worried a lot of people are um
about the coming economic downturn
already many people are being affected
by it
um and the warning that's coming from a
lot of pension analysts saying to people
who are potentially withdrawing uh
pensions over three and a half billion I
think so far has been has been withdrawn
out of the nation's Pension funds and
they're saying look if you do this you
just need to be aware that you are
obviously putting your own Futures in
Jeopardy you know potentially you know
uh uh you know not being able to have
the quality of living uh that you might
expect might not you know might struggle
in fact to get by now one might temper
that by saying that one would hope that
people were sensible enough
um to not take out more than that they
could afford to realistically but we
already know this that people have a you
know the the younger Generations
Millennials and below a lot of them are
really struggling it's it's not
necessarily a situation where they can
go oh it's fine I'll just get by and I'm
sure actually a lot of uh parents
especially those who have paid off their
own mortgages who have had you know who
do have quite good pensions who have had
it relatively easy I'm sure a lot of
them actually feel a little bit bad
given the situation the burden of tax
for example is being placed on younger
people their inability to get on the
housing out of their inability to start
families their inability to save for
their own futures
um as much as anything else I'm sure
that there is an element of that going
on as well and a lot of elderly people
as well a lot of older people a lot of
Pensions will be saying look at some
point you know I've created this sort of
Nest maybe with the hope of passing it
on to my children maybe I have to give
them a little bit now to sort of help
them get through because it is going to
be a very difficult to start helping
them a bit earlier than they'd planned
let's just take a quick look at the
Telegraph and this is uh the Princess of
Wales
um charity well her work her future work
is going to be with helping the Under
Fire shining a light on
the under fives
Susie
yeah well actually this is her work for
the past sort of 10 years and she's
continuing with it so the telegrapher
sort of managed to find a way of saying
that she's carving out a future for
herself by doing the same thing she's
already been doing
um she's perfectly right and it's
brilliant that there's someone uh with
her profile who is
um focusing on those first sort of
thousand days of a child's life the
first three years and then the first
five years those earlier stages in which
if you get the right nutrition if you
get the right care if you get the right
family background that your future is
going to be very very different to those
who don't have those things and
concentrating on that and making sure
every child has access to those things
is incredibly important I think she's
probably
gonna struggle we're under the current
government to get funding for that sort
of stuff but we'll have to see how
things go over the long term won't we
but what's great about it I suppose in a
way is that as well the Princess of
Wales actually get us to express an
opinion about things she says not
enough's being done on this we need to
do more need do better now can you
remember I'm old enough to remember
actually when the last Princess of Wales
did start saying things like this isn't
good enough something needs to be done
about it and all the papers were up in
our arms saying how dare Princess Diana
starts sticking her oil and tell us what
to do uh she's got no right Etc so it's
good
expressing a view Susie and benedict for
the moment thank you we're going to take
a break coming up a tree over front
pages to make Bruce Springsteen blush
the red tops aren't too happy about
tonight's World Cup result for England
or on that next stay with us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're watching the Press preview still
with me Susie Boniface and Benedict
Spence welcome back to you both um let's
have a look at the
star to start with uh Benedict um Johan
in the USA explain the headline
any of you watching we're not watching
earlier the England versus United States
match um you didn't miss anything it was
a pretty much the worst game of the
World Cup so far as ever with England
having won their first game I think six
one six two or something like that yeah
they were always going to let us down
after that it was an absolute snore
first
um if anything the United States was
slightly better just to add insults to
injury
um uh yeah it doesn't it's not great
in all honesty it does make things a
little bit more difficult for England
qualifying but it was nothing on the
earlier game Wells versus Iran which was
you know very tense full of excitement
and high drama
um with a you know the dramatic finish
right at the end um that was the other
game in England's group and it now
leaves us very interestingly poised
shall we say Iran versus uh USA that old
Humdinger
um for the next round and then of course
England versus Wales and it pretty much
seems to be a Winner Takes all situation
for both teams yes sir we shall see the
result of that uh nail biting style
sound at mirror all the same headline
there um Susie take us to the ft and
this story about the qataris um thinking
about withdrawing investment in London
because of um
the London transport
advertising bans on Qatari adverts
yep so the uh you know the generally
poor PR that Qatar has had throughout
the world cup about its complete
inability to accept that some human
beings are other than the norm should we
say the the median I don't know how I
would consider it but there is a
spectrum and a range of human existence
put it that way
um has meant that London transport has
taken some of the qatar's ads off its
buses and trains and Qatar is now
reviewing whether it wishes to invest in
various things in London
um it's a bit of a Tit for Tat guitar's
obviously got a lot of money London
obviously likes that money but by the
same token you have to start deciding at
some point at what point the money
you're taking or spending is dirty or
clean and whether it's the money that
you want whether it's the kind of
investment you choose to have
um and I think you know getting the
World Cup which Qatar won at the height
of FIFA being perhaps the most corrupt
it's ever been which is saying something
um it was darling in order to make Qatar
seem like a better place
it's not worked
sorry Susie to to cut in there uh
Benedict just very quickly your your
thoughts on that about 20 seconds
um I think tfl is probably right to do
it well within the right story it
possibly should have done it earlier
though we haven't known the World Cup
was going to be in Qatar for about 12
years
um but I do think it sets an interesting
precedent because actually the biggest
campaigns right now that I've seen on
the tube for example are from Morocco a
holiday you know a campaign saying come
to Morocco homosexuality is illegal in
Morocco and also a lot for money
transfer codes for African countries
Ghana Nigeria homosexuality people there
as well thank you so much we've run out
of time